mind your decisions i'm presh tallwalker
4 to the power of x plus 6 to the power
of x is equal to 9 to the power of x
solve for all real values of x that
satisfy this equation
i think rithwick in india for suggesting
this problem it came from an iit jee
sample paper
but i've also seen it shared on the
internet with the catchphrase you should
be able to solve this
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
we'll get started by dividing each term
by four to the power of x
the first term simplifies to be one
the next term becomes six over four all
raised to the power of x and the third
term becomes nine over four raised to
the power of x
six over four is equal to three over two
and we'll substitute that in
nine over four is equal to three over
two the quantity squared and we'll
substitute that in
we now simplify 3 over 2 squared all
raised to the power of x
this becomes 3 over 2 all raised to the
power of 2x
now make the substitution that 3 over 2
raised to the power of x is equal to u
if we square both sides of the equation
we get 3 over 2 all raised to the power
of 2x is equal to u squared
we thus have a quadratic equation 1 plus
u is equal to u squared
we'll move the terms to the right hand
side so we get 0 is equal to u squared
minus u minus 1.
since u is equal to 3 over 2 all raised
to the power of x we need u to be
greater than 0 because 3 halves raised
to the power of x will be a positive
term
we then use the quadratic formula and
simplify
we get that u is equal to the golden
ratio 1 plus the square root of 5 all
over 2
but we're not done yet we want to solve
for x
since 3 halves raised to the power of x
is equal to u
we want to solve for x by taking the
natural log of both sides
we can then bring the exponent down and
then solve for x by dividing by the
natural log of 3 halves
we substitute in for u and we get our
exact answer
x is equal to the natural log of the
golden ratio divided by the natural log
of 3 halves and this simplifies to be
approximately 1.187
at first the problem was quite
intimidating but with some clever
substitutions we found the golden answer
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube as
always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
you